apple yesterday announced two m1 chips
and a super powered like massively super
powered 16-inch macbook pro at their
unleashed event apple announced two new
chips you know they came out the m1
about 11 months ago november 2020
and that uh chip uh performed twice as
fast as the latest pc laptop chips while
using less power and that is the key for
a laptop isn't it you want more power
but less power consumption so you want
to be able to process more graphics
while not training your battery
specialized chips
will do better at this task as opposed
to general chips and we are very far
into the silicon race here we're in the
fifth or sixth decade of making these
chips uh 70s 80s 90s yeah so you know
we're now into the sixth
decade of making these kind of chips for
pcs
and
everybody knows that the key issue is
battery life that we all contend with
and because apple was building off of
over a billion ios devices they really
got to optimize chips and they went full
stack if apple is not dependent on intel
or amd or other chip manufacturers it
makes it a stronger and more valuable
company and that's what you see over
time companies build full stack tesla
one of the greatest examples of this
they make their own battery packs they
don't take them from panasonic or
whoever anymore i think in the beginning
they were using actually panasonic
batteries in the roadster and so if you
want to have a company that is less
uh dependent on third parties and you
want to capture more of the margin in
your product why give that margin to
other players in the space because
they're they have to make their hundred
dollars or 200 off of a chip that's why
pcs if you had an intel chip versus an
amd versus some you know generic ship
they could have a difference of 100 200
bucks
so there is a financial incentive here
but there's also how do we make the best
possible experience for our consumer
base what does their consumer base do
well they're not gamers as much as they
are video editors and creators and
creatives that's always been who the the
mac ecosystem goes after why because if
you're a creator you appreciate
something beautiful it was steve jobs
passion
and those people
who are creatives are price insensitive
they're price insensitive if you are
making content on your computer your
video editor you're a screenplay writer
an author
you're making money making content this
is the content creation device so that's
part of the secret you're not just using
it for email if you're using it for
email yeah buy a chromebook
you're going to be able to spend 500
bucks and there's no difference between
doing email on a 3000 machine or a 500
big difference doing video editing big
difference doing uh photography etc and
so
let's talk a little bit about these two
new chips one's called the m1 pro one's
called the m1 max confusing branding
here but you see where they're going
they're gonna have three chips the chips
will have different uh profiles in terms
of power here you can see i guess that's
the physical representation in terms of
size and that is indicative of what
they're capable of doing
and uh
here's a 40 second clip explaining the
specs of the m1 max chip specifically 39
seconds i'll see on the other side
m1 max starts with a much higher
bandwidth on-chip fabric and doubles the
memory interface once again this
delivers up to 400 gigabytes per second
of memory bandwidth that's twice in one
pro and six times m1 this wider memory
interface lets the m1 custom package
support up to 64 gigabytes of unified
memory and its die has a staggering 57
billion transistors that's 1.7 times m1
pro and 3.5 times m1 it's the largest
chip we've ever built by far m1 max has
the same powerful 10 core cpu complex of
m1 pro and doubles the gpu to a massive
32 cores giving m1 max up to 4 times
faster gpu performance than m1
all right so as you can see it's
massively massively uh faster and more
powerful and
they are using less power than like
these eight core pc chips uh so to get
the same amount of pc graphics you can
do it but it's going to have a higher
uh power profile which means your
machine is going to have the battery die
very
quickly
and in an april uh earnings call tim
cook warned that the global chip
shortage would impact apple's m1 chips
and the products associated with them
according to apple rumors all apple
chips including the new m1s are
manufactured at tsmc
if you're wondering what the t stands
for it's taiwan and if you've been
listening to all in or this podcast we
had jacob on recently to talk about
taiwan
been watching the news you know that
taiwan has a bunch of chinese airplanes
flying around in the south china sea you
have military maneuvers with the big six
new zealand australia japan the uk
the united states
and south korea i think those are the
big six in the south pacific
and they are
of course uh now trying to
at least let china know that we're not
going to let you roll taiwan
and i think the taiwan uh semiconductor
manufacturing company tsmc is a big part
of this if you just think about that one
company 500 billion dollar company
produces a lot of the world silicon
it is if you want to talk about supply
chain interruption if china takes over
uh tsmc and they take over taiwan by you
know if they take over taiwan and by
extension they might just seize tsmc and
your state of yourself that's crazy
governments don't just seize companies
isn't that what they just did in china
so
a lot of what's happening here in terms
of the independence of taiwan
could have something to do with tsmc as
part of that japan is subsidizing a
seven billion dollar plant that tsmc is
building sony's an investor in as well
in japan
and tsmc is also building a plant i
believe in arizona here in the united
states and so what we're going to see is
different governments spending money
with tsmc to move their factories to
secure locations this would be a great
thing for australia new zealand
uh korea other countries to do if we can
make tsmc a global company with a gold
global footprint of factories that would
make the supply chain much more
resilient and everybody has a horse in
that race
including china where's apple in all
this apple has 250 billion dollars in
cash last time i checked well over 200
billion
why doesn't apple just buy tsmc i guess
that would be considered a uh a real
uh hostile act by the chinese government
and why doesn't apple give seven billion
dollars to tsmc to build a plant you
know in vietnam or korea or somewhere
else again
the chinese philosophy of war and
interactions is
just
saying that taiwan is its own sovereign
country that would be considered
according to the doctrines in china
an act of war based on what i've read if
you want to watch the jacob hellberg
episode it was episode 1303 just last
week and a great new book from him so
totally uh worth watching
when you're trying to nail an important
project you're going to need some extra
help right you're trying to move fast
you're a startup well fiverr business
puts a world of expert freelancers at
your fingertips so you can get any
project across the finish line and be
really proud of your work plus you'll
get everything you need to seamlessly
integrate your new team members into
your workflow we love fiverr here at
launch we've hired a bunch of
researchers to find local founders to
invite to different launch events that
was one of my secret weapons so stop
wasting your time searching for creative
talent just leave it to fiverr business
their team of dedicated business success
managers help match you with the best
talent for your team there's no more
endless guessing and interviews and
people disappearing that was always my
problem because freelancers were so so
unreliable well not anymore use fiverr
for business and you will not have that
problem plus you can save and share your
favorite freelancers for future projects
so find the right freelancers you need
to give your next project just the boost
it needs to finish strong right now you
can sign up for fiverr business
absolutely free for the first year get
one year free and save 10
on your purchase of fiverr business with
the promo code jason yes that's right
j-a-s-o-n just go to fiverr.com business
f i v e r r dot com slash business
f i v e r r dot com business and don't
forget to use that promo code jason